babe yes a moment of silence for our
queen yes
she retired she retired but she lives on
in our hearts
and late at night when i'm trying to
sleep i don't count sheep i can't
yolanda vega calling out ball numbers
that's what i do yolanda vega we love
you there's a home here third mike
yolanda vega we wish her the best we
wish her the best she is part of new
york she's part of making dreams come
true she made all my dreams come true
yolanda vega she gave me the strength
and courage to put february 11th the the
in washington dc i will be at the warner
theater she gave me the strength to put
february 11th at the warner theatre in
washington d.c and february 12 at the
tabernacle atlanta georgia for homeless
plymouth's birthday show
she gave me the strength to put those on
sale i'll tell you right now you're
going to be in d.c then i'm going to be
in dc february 19th warner theater no
not the warner theater uh somewhere else
that i'm forgetting okay okay uh fudge i
should have remembered yeah all right
listen yolanda vega she recently retired
and guess what yolanda vega my life
wouldn't be the same she gave me the
strength and courage to go
to washington dc on february 11th at the
warner theater and do stand-up comedy
i'll be at christiecomedy.com february
11th warner theatre washington dc and
then the very next night february 12th
the tabernacle atlanta georgia for
homeless pimp's birthday show february
12th beautiful and i'm going to dc she
gave me that strength but she gave me
this trend to go to dc on february 19th
and there i'm playing the
capital one hall the night before that
i'm in albany playing the egg on
february 18th i mean the egg is the best
and we sold out the first one trying to
sell out the second egg because who
orders one egg nobody orders one egg you
gotta have eggs you gotta break couple
eggs and make an omelette february 26th
i will be at the borgata in atlantic
city that show was rescheduled because
of the snowstorm march 4th i will be in
royal oak michigan at the royal oak
music theater and march 5th agora
theater cleveland ohio i just played the
agora it was a hot show i loved it
you're going to love it there really
playing the royal oak theater when march
4th i'm playing it february 11th uh
unless it happened already no it's
happening this coming week yes february
11th at the royal oak and uh right
outside detroit february 12th at
pittsburgh in at the freaking i can't i
don't remember the music carnegie
carnegie of homestead music hall andrew
carnegie homestead steakhouse the second
show's in all these places that's what
we're trying to sell out get this
avocado company.com listen to this babe
and then also we got a documentary
coming out on
youtube.compresh that homeless pimp uh
film the documentary of taste buds and
hey bay behind the scenes stuff it's
going to be touring behind
everything it's a fully real life like
it's a two-hour job
also like and subscribe to our youtube
page okay you need to like subscribe
spotify
leave us a rating give us a follow beat
the [ __ ] out of you yeah it means it's
gone we never ask we never ask for
anything but it means a lot ask if you
want to get
the absolute [ __ ] kicked out of you yeah
if you do
then you won't like it subscribe to the
podcast correct if you don't then like
and subscribe me and chris you're at the
ryman march 11th nashville tennessee
[Music]
what's going on babe babe how wild were
those football games
on sunday
i mean this is one of the best playoff
years that i can remember in a while
although i usually forget the playoffs
right after they happen right but i mean
these have been down to the wire two
minute drill ot type games it's
literally literally literally literally
one of the best football seasons i i
mean i was watching it
last night or well a few nights ago
and i couldn't believe i was saying if
the rams win if the rams win it will be
for the second year in a row the home
team playing in the home stadium of the
super bowl which had never happened
before right before tom brady won it
right
shout out tom shout out tom brady yeah
shout out tom brady he won they won the
super bowl this year correct well last
year day one last year right in tampa in
tampa yeah he's the oldest person in the
nfl anyone yeah he led his team there
and
you know i would be having it paddy mom
patrick holmes who just was eliminated
from the playoffs but he's gonna have a
good year and it's not gonna happen this
season but maybe it'll happen next
season for patrick mahomes yeah you
gotta count talented squad there
councils
clyde edwards you got down hill you got
kelsey
yes there's a lot of people you got a
lot of great great o-line there great he
sits in the pocket like he has like he
can file his nails and and put on lee
press-ons he has all the time in the
world 100
yeah and then tom brady retired and then
didn't retire and now is he retired or
not i don't know they're saying they're
saying that uh they're blaming it on his
wife gisele bundchen uh that they're
saying that she's the one that spread it
but tommy b said he could oh i didn't
say that i didn't say it now will he
retire or not uh yo no say right do i
think he should retire
no because i'll tell you what we're not
because he was the best he was the
leading quarterback in the nfl yeah
there's no reason by the way he did what
he was supposed to do he marched down
that field he did his two-minute drill
and he got them in the game again yeah i
just can't believe that and then they
came back and lost yeah just it's it's
almost it's almost not his fault at all
i mean
you know uh um
who beat him um
who beat the box
uh it wasn't the rams
yeah was the rams the rams it was the
rounds the rams in tampa because i was
at the tampa theater it was the next
night and then i was going to l.a so all
the rams fans were coming into tampa and
i was leaving and stafford got back
downfield and and they got out yeah yeah
i now stay i mean listen it's great even
stafford now
you know um he's a good story too i mean
he was on the detroit lions for all
those years just
you know doing nothing floundering away
and i was and that was in the s
shout out
shout out
shout out matthew stafford shout out
matthew safford shout out to cincinnati
i mean the cincinnati bengals i mean
i got a roof for them by the way
everybody because here's the thing if it
would have been the chiefs rams it would
have been kind of a boring super bowl
but the bengals make it fun yeah the
bengals make it fun i cannot believe
they won last i don't think they've been
in the super bowl since when 1988 ikky
woods or something like that or nothing
even before that 8 or 89 yeah they are
never in contention never ever they're a
fun team they're a scrappy teen they're
a young team and and it's nice a bengal
is a nice animal because you don't hear
about bengals too much everyone's always
talking about lions and tigers and bears
all mine but nothing about bengals yeah
and a bengal i mean a bengal's a
gorgeous animal what's their stream a
bengal and a tiger do we know that
there's between a bengal in a time not a
clue not a clue no you could put you
could put a suitcase down right now with
a hundred million
untraced unmarked bills
and i wouldn't be able to answer it here
it is siberian tiger has more siberian
tiger tigers are from siberia i mean
they don't blend in they're bright
orange
siberian tiger has very thick pale gold
and a rusty red coat covered with black
stripes belly is white colored bengal
tiger has thin light yellow fur with
brown or black stripes belly and inner
parts of legs or white colored so so
that's interesting so the bengal pull up
a picture of a bengal not from
cincinnati but pull up i mean
while you're in the first target you
can't you can't tell the difference pull
up a picture of susanna hoff's
yes
do you know who that is
is that the one with one leg from
dancing with the stars no no
she's the lead singer of the bengals oh
okay not the bengals the bangles the
bangles but she's a
lifelong
gorgeous i mean she's a lifelong crush
oh yes
oh my god speaking of music i mean
listen
this is not this is not uh you know
about where we stand i look real good
today i look real good today
um
i mean you got to feel
you even if you're a huge fan even if
you're a huge fan and don't want to get
involved in this controversy at all
whatever but even if you're a huge fan
you got neil young has to feel pretty
dumb that he said i'm gonna it's either
me or joe rogan spotify and spotify
deliberated for 30 minutes and took neil
young's music immediately off the
platform he's probably i mean
immediately they just said we choose joe
suck it neal he's probably not getting
11 million downloads a song right now
right but did you hear what happened
though
i read an article okay that said that in
the wake of that news because now joni
mitchell came through and now they're
saying the flu
no relation to paul mitchell johnny
mitchell right now the hair's the hair
guy right no he's in salons she's in
cafes strumming got it okay so
by the way
i gotta say i love this look you like it
it looks like abercrombie
and fitch it looks like you just played
tennis maybe polo looks like you came
from the polo grounds yeah you look
preppy you look wasp
that's what i'm going for you look like
you come from from wealth well i'm going
christy connecticut this is this is this
character yeah you look like a brunch
yes you look like you vacation for the
summer absolutely what i like what i'd
like sir is a lobster roll and a seltzer
and uh aristotle arrows
as per all spreads aperol sprints
you look like you asked people where do
you summer that's when you know you made
it yeah when you asked people where they
go for the entire summer yeah up and you
know those people i hate when people go
where do you vacation yeah
i well where i summer at splish splash
at the end of the live
[Laughter]
in suffolk county long island i'm over
at io i'm over at the uh sesame place
over in langhorne yes
um so so what was the controversy i
heard that in the wake so other artists
are following suit now there's somebody
dying
no it's at the wake
in the wake of the controversy i thought
you said you were out of weight you
heard it no uh in the wake of the
controversy joni mitchell chimed and now
i heard that other other bands and other
big musicians are possibly thinking
about following suit and i heard i heard
i know this is hearsay i heard one of
them is the foo fighters which would be
a swift kick in the spotify balls but i
will tell you i read an article that
said their stock dropped uh and they
lost four billion dollars spotify
spotify spotify
lost four billion wow see because that's
what this is about is a lot of things
because it is it is easy because
perception is reality right so if the
perception that spotify is going down
then they lost money now spotify has to
listen even if the even if they are
getting twelve
by the way just want to say this isn't
calm this is hair gel just fyi well i'm
disappointed okay uh can you pull up sp
spotify four billion stock
now what is now let's say he gets kicked
off spotify joey roro did you just go
back to the tube
i guess right i don't know you gotta go
back to yt
what do we got no but is it
it said that they lost four billion
bucks four billion dollars yeah no is
that i would say that's why did stock
spotify stock drop maybe right there who
knows when that is by the way you know
what i'm having for dinner tonight stuff
here spotify shares were down by 12
percent the week after the neil young
requested his music be removed blah blah
blah in a post to site on friday young
said he felt better that he left uh 12
percent here
okay 12 percent
read that by friday spotify loss lost
four billion dollars in market value the
san francisco chronicle date book
reported wow so four bill but still
they're standing by joe rogan so do you
think that he's bringing in more than
they're losing well what happened they
paid him a hundred mil right something
like that i thought he just slapped a
fly
they paid him a hundred mil so imagine
what they're making off of him if
they're paying him 100 well because joe
rogan allegedly he had went down when he
first on spotify deal people were angry
he was off youtube he wasn't getting the
viewership but now he's back up to 12 to
15 million views in episode really on
spotify back he's back up to his numbers
at youtube that's what they say
because i think all the covet stuff and
you know he's become such a folk hero i
mean all it shows you is that it's it's
just about the money
it shows me when when people get
canceled it's because uh a lot of times
when they when people get canceled
especially immediately it's because the
corporations are afraid of the public
blowback because they're afraid of their
stock prices they're afraid of
everything to dip and they make
decisions based not really on right or
wrong per se yes but more so like money
that's why sometimes there's a
controversy that isn't even rectified
yet and that person is done yeah the the
people want to be in those waters the
people who own those companies might
very well agree with the person they're
firing but they like you said it's it's
the perception's reality so they get it
the device goes down they said two
things they said get me uh the joe rogan
file get me the neil young file yes and
then they went like this they saw a
number and they went down they saw a
number they go we don't agree with neil
young yes that's what happened see you
later alligator yeah um yeah so but if
if more artists start doing it i mean
look he probably has all the money he's
gonna make i don't know like he's he
probably could afford to do it i don't
know if younger artists can but he's
still streaming everywhere else should
we pull our stuff off spotify i don't
even think we get paid for it right i
don't think comedians and podcasts
here's here's here's what me and salah
doing how do we get paid we're putting
more episodes on spotify that's right
we're putting more content on spotify
that's right yeah we should begin but
well there's that's a big controversy
why don't we get paid
why don't comics and podcasters get paid
for their you know albums or plays or
whatever like it's frustrating too
because all these nft people are making
millions and they're doing nothing
justin bieber buys uh buys board ape nft
for 1.29 million now the board ape nft
thing is a big thing it's like a radical
thing that's happening but
i would invest in the metaverse and of
course you know him chrissy crypto but
the board ape thing just seems like a
scam does it not pimpy that's it right
there that's the price of the house you
bought yes 1.29 million
yes you know what i'm saying
so you could shelter your family
indefinitely indefinitely or you could
have that cartoon ape on a digital file
well i'm gonna have to break the news to
my kids tonight
we're getting a cartoon what's funny is
that might appreciate quicker than your
house 100 real estate is the is the big
it's the investment that has stood the
test of time right yes it'll go up no
matter what no matter what you can it's
a long term but you invest in real
estate you can't go wrong hundred
percent and this might a cartoon of a
board eight might be might be a real
estate investor speaking of investing i
just want to say something that's out of
left field but your hair is on fire
today i mean it has reached this day it
has we have went through the awkward
phase we had went through the now it is
now it is just i mean it's it's it's
classic
almost healthy hair i almost cut it what
like in the last two weeks i tried to
cut it three times that'd be a power
move if you did that yeah just to be
like you know what i grew it out to this
thing and that's what i do when i get in
shape i get my body all the way down so
i'm ripped i said i'll get fat again in
a month
that's what i do
people have something over on me yeah
i'll get fat again look at these tits
so wow so you almost cut it and what
happened the power i got sick and tired
of it but i don't do it the right way
because i never can do it with the way
he does it when i leave there so then
that i finally got you know i got some
tips and tricks uh from the lady and
then she she she and i'm like all right
now it's passable here's what i don't
like i don't like going on stage with it
because because i sweat on stage and my
hair gets frizzy and puffy and curly and
it just goes
yeah but see that's and it looks like so
i'm wearing hats on stage i sweat in the
hat my face is covered a little bit i
don't like that because when you come
out because after you after your
performance you that you have sex hair
yeah you have to show you upset it looks
like the crowd it looks like you just
had sex with the crowd correct which i
did
[Laughter]
is such an italian like regional thing
yeah like i don't think everybody knows
peach peach good deal it means good deal
is like yeah and a real italian guy
would say that that's the name for his
penis yeah the pisces i don't know if
a deal would mean nothing else but penis
in my opinion i wouldn't say i don't
know how you should get those
people
in anything is it like
i
favorite garbage italian slang that's
what it says
can we see yeah you know what some
people put a c in there they say pischka
deal into the pizza deal i go pish kadio
i like to make mine a little eastern
european peach
uh yeah so on what is picha deal
old-school italian slang for mexico
genitalia hashtag mob
okay
um does anyone know that is that like
italian italian or is that like here
italian i think that's new york italian
i think that that's one of those slangs
like it's new york i think you go to
italy you know even in italy and are
telling fans correctly from wrong but i
know a a an italian relatively famous
italian man his name is franco
falconetti [ __ ] but he's huge he uh
as a matter of fact um conor mcgregor
punch him in the face i did the ultimate
beast master with this guy yeah go up uh
[ __ ] eddie f-a-c-c
f-a-c-c-h-i
yeah friend francesco facanetti conor
mcgregor punched him in the face for
what you see uh i don't know he just got
crazy at a party but i've known this guy
since 2016 with the ultimate beastmaster
together on netflix which i was fired
from um but fran franco falconetti told
me that in italy you know he's from he
by the way his his um his father is a
famous musician from a band called pooh
the name of the band is pooh
and they're humongous in italy wow
italian pan poo yeah poop
come from a pool
look where pooh was formed uh
oh bologna bologna
pool and he's
falling from bologna it was a beautiful
time and we have a hundred thousand
people yelling poo
um so poo so so yeah robbie [ __ ]
eddie see so he said from pooh it's this
guy's great francisco uh franco [ __ ]
eddie is the best i love we talk
sometimes well
he goes i remember because you know how
covet hit italy first yeah i remember
like there was a time when you know
nobody thought that cover was going to
come here like that and then i remember
he sent me what's up he says call if
it's coming he's going to kill everybody
he goes in italy killing ever you're
going to kill everybody very soon no and
i was like thanks and that was the whole
voice it might kill your whole family
and i was like thank you
franklin to you my first and only son i
leave you eighty percent of the pool
pool
um do you like pool
so uh [ __ ] eddie told me that
fettuccine alfredo is an american thing
it's not real in italy he said if you go
to italy and go can't get fettuccino
alfredo they would know either an
american tourist idiot and they or
they'd say no they don't know what they
said who's he's afraid
there's no afraid did you know that no
that's an american thing no idea
fettuccine alfredo's a completely
made-up american thing wait wait why did
you bring up [ __ ] to begin with
because because we were talking about
things that are um words and that are
made up of peace
and other things in italy that are made
up like alfredo right i know that's why
i brought a franco [ __ ] bishop deal
would be a good name for uh
should we have a beer called
a band or or maybe a comedy special
um
so so yeah dude so so um um
uh with uh [ __ ] eddie what we were
talking about with something we came off
of it bangles all bangles yeah back to
the bengals basically yeah let's bring
it back to the bengals bengals who's uh
benoti fettuccine alfredo and boo
um siberia yeah we were talking about
the synthetic here we go boarding
so is this one person making all the
apes i have no clue is is it pimp it's
called knows about the stuff
oh baby draftkings the moment we've been
waiting for since september is finally
here i mean if you can't i can't even
watch sports anymore without watching
them through draftkings just because
it just gives the game so much more
flavor it's so much more exciting i'm
not a professional athlete but so
sometimes it gets a little boring and
i'm not a professional gambler i'm not a
professional gamble either but guess
what you don't have to be i understand
with draftkings because right now if you
download the draftkings sportsbook app
okay they're giving new customers
wait what is that real a free shot at a
million dollars okay official sports
betting partners super bowl 56 new
customers 56 to one odds on either team
bet five bucks and get 280 in free bets
if your team wins yes so that's insane
and if it's now it's live in new york
meaning you can bet from almost a third
of the country so one third of the
country you can bet from free shot at
one million dollars top prize with their
first deposit and if you download the
draftking sportsbook app right now and
use the promo code hey babe and get 56
to one odds on either uh you will get 56
to one odds on either team what really
you just bet five bucks
and get 280 in free bets if the team
wins wow and then you could roll that
you could roll that too so that's the
promo code hey babe at draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of super bowl 56. 21 plus
minimum age and location requirements
vary by jurisdiction c drafting
draftkings.com sportsbook for full list
of requirements and state-specific
responsible gaming resources voidware
prohibited gambling problem called 1-800
gambler in tennessee call or text tn
redline
call
1-800-889-9789
or visit
ccpg.org chat in new york call 877 8
hope ny or text hope ny at 467-369.
listen two out of three men
here's what's gonna happen in two or
three men they're gonna experience some
sort of hair loss in their lifetime and
their wives will cheat by the age of 35
by the age of 35 more than 50 million
men in the u.s
and keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors and that's
any of its competitors and there's only
two fda approved medications that can
prevent hair loss and guess who hasn't
offers them both keeps they got them
both baby simple affordable stress-free
way to keep your hair
via convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your dough every three
months you don't have to leave your home
24 7 care and support keeps has a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality and it's a low cost treatment
start at just 10 bucks a month and keeps
offers generic versions of the two fda
approved medications to prevent your
hair loss so treatments are affordable
typically half the price of pharmacies
when it comes to your hair save more
spend less if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe to
receive your first to receive your first
month of treatment for free baby that's
k-e-e-p dot com slash hey babe get your
first month for read k-e-e-e-p-s dot com
slash hey babe
yacht club it kind of might be a vape
right that's right
i thought bait was born a pimp it's a
different thing no it's this is just an
artist collection
like he made only i think a hundred
thousand of these 100 only exists on the
metaverse so this board apiac club these
are nfts
but but don't nfts only exist in the
metaverse i no they exist in the
blockchain
a limited nft collection where the token
itself
doubles as your membership to a swamp
club for apes the club is open ape in
with us
but my question is is this board eight
yacht board ape yacht club
isn't physically here am i right right
about that it only exists online correct
so should we try to buy a board ape
right now do you want to buy a board ape
how much are they okay let's read it
let's get into this right now 300k the
boy but are they but who's going to buy
one from me
i spent 300k on a cartoon jimmy fallon
just bought what justin bieber bought it
300 above what it went for
why because he must have liked the
design the collection of ten thousand
ape avatars that individually act as
tickets to an online social club has
become one of the most prominent brands
in the nft space and now the nfts have
generated more than one billion in total
sales
can i use can i get uh can i get a board
ape ticket and get into the show house
with that
yeah this is like even more useless than
the soho house they have an average
they have an average sale of over 200
000 as of this writing which was a
couple of weeks ago with a growing list
of celebrity owners ranging from
shaquille o'neal to mnm to stephen curry
stefan curry to steve aoki
one time i saw steve aoki at a at a
breakfast in a hotel in la and he was
wearing um like big huge headphones and
i'll never forget he ordered three green
juices and three plates of bacon i don't
know what the hell he was and he just
ate he ate and drank all of them isn't
he ripped
he's like yeah it's like uh he's small
but he ordered three green juices and
three
three plates of just bacon wow okay
that's when they had headphones on he
was like you know on his laptop which
are not a lot to do with the soho house
no you're not no no wonder he's dressing
this way
are you trying to get in
wait do you want to get into the soul
house
i got drunk and joined no you didn't i
got smashed when three weeks no no sally
three weeks ago he sent me a text he
joined soho house and bought louboutin
shoes i was like i woke up the next
morning no memory of it louboutin shoes
i bought louis baton seekers
louis vuitton louboutin louboutin i
bought louboutin sneakers for me and
louboutin high heels for tt jerry no you
didn't swear to god how much was that
like three thousand dollars no yeah all
on credit
it's bad they're wearing to the beacon
on saturday in new york you're wearing
louboutins i'm gonna wear the louboutin
sneakers and tt's gonna wear the match
in high heels and then i also joined the
soho house
in one night and one night what what
were you drinking martinis where after
soho house i was a guest no you were
quick
[Music]
you were a guest at the sauce and you
just drank martinis then you joined you
went and s and you joined right there
that no because i was sitting with
emilio who's a member and then he goes
you should join i go you're right i
should and then so so i was drinking
martinis and you know you have to sign
up and all that yeah and then i think
they have to give you like a think you
have to get two people to refer you then
you have to fill out a form so the guy
who i was sitting with gave me his
referral right then yeah and then one of
the you know general managers or
something that was there as a friend was
like just put my name down you'll get in
just put mine here so i do that barely
remembering this get through it stumble
through it wake up the next morning fill
it out i'm no well online yeah yeah
yeah uh the next morning wake up i have
a three thousand dollar charge from
american express i said i'm disputing
that's who [ __ ] about louis
louis
bataan
[Laughter]
it's louis vuitton right no and
louboutins i call them louis batons no
wait isn't that true that's two
different things
louboutin is not louis vuitton i bought
louboutins
this whatever yeah yeah yeah christian
christian louboutins um i bought
matching uh sneaks yeah red butt i
bought sneakers and uh and high heel
shoes and you bought
with petit
was she right there
i i texted jazz i said what's tt jerry's
shoe size and she was like 12 and a half
boom got him 12 and a half high heel
pumps
those are the ones i got and then
matching ones with with tt yeah these
are the ones i got
they wouldn't cost 9.95 maybe they did
i mean what's crazy is it's a stupid
thing and i i paid that amount of money
for sneakers when i started collecting
sneaky i don't even like them they look
cool i mean they i don't like them i
don't like them in the slightest i don't
like them like truthfully at all as a
matter of fact after the beacon show
i'll sell them i mean i'll sell for half
price just to get some money back i mean
whatever i don't want them at all i
stayed the other night at his house it
was so funny his daughter ran in the
room and said you want to see my dad's
louboutins no
yeah god delilah had my had tt jerry's
high heels on oh my gosh so i did that
and then the soho and then and then i
have an email from the soho house being
like your application is being um
reviewed reviewed and i said what the
hell so i said what what what happened
here and then i got in and then they and
then i got in and you just get charged i
mean yeah you just got shot yeah they
actually just charged me for this month
this this cycle oh so you remember yeah
oh so how do you go nah
how many times have you been why don't
we do a no-press night at the soho house
oh yeah it doesn't
will be thrown out you want a social
club joey roses
you're allowed three guests each and as
you call ahead sometimes you can get
like special how many times have you
truthfully been in
i've been i've been a part of this the
thing for
i want to say four or five can you guys
explain what it is because i didn't know
so it's all it is is like a
there's many of them like all over the
world there's many soho houses all over
the world but there's other social clubs
like it yeah there's like four or five
of them in new york they're around it's
basically like you pay a membership fee
to have access to their amenities and
they usually have a really like nice
it's like a restaurant bar hotel lounge
workspace event space they bring people
together they have all different events
there it's just networking and
socializing you're not allowed to have
phones out you're not allowed to bother
anybody if there's a celebrity there so
a lot of times you can't even talk to
anybody really right you're not supposed
to talk to strangers no you you can you
can but they're supposed to not
no one's allowed to take photographs or
have their phones out or ball like
go up to approach celebrities
quote-unquote so that's why like it's
really not comprised of celebrities it's
i mean it's mostly like it's for
creative times creative types yeah so
you guys pay for a ticket to a community
of people with the same ticket
so it's this is the nft this is an nft
guy it's kind of like
a membership right
is it worth it
yeah is it um well it depends what you
use it for right so like i know people
that always there's four or five of
these houses in new york yeah and
they're always in there like in between
you know work or this or that or writing
or going in there it's like a place you
can go because you can't run you can't
have your laptop out post up i thought
you could
oh i thought you could have your laptop
out maybe i'm wrong then but but but
when you go like would you ever just go
for dinner yeah drinks so for me i just
use it as a place to go where i don't
need a reservation that i can go and
bring people and not worry about people
ostensibly not worried about people
bothering me although every time i've
ever gone people still bother me when
have you when have you ever been the
last one across the country they
bothered me when is the last time you
went so the one here probably
uh
in the summer
you want to go yeah i'll go there's like
three there's like three out there's
like three or four did you buy the world
membership world okay i think that's the
way to do it so like when you're in
london or in austin or in nashville or
in chicago or in any of these places and
they have it just go you have access to
one of the hotels there i never did you
have a little price you have access to
that too where people don't which i
think is odd you need access to
or or discounted maybe i don't know well
they're going to take this further now
there's nft restaurants launching what
does that mean an nft restaurant opening
in new york will serve up status with a
sign of seafood what does that mean
though yeah so like but my question is
the nft like is it is it an edible nft
or you're saying
regular membership token on the second
so you pretty much buy like whatever the
like uh the board ape thing and it acts
as a ticket to the social club that's
gonna be can i only use it once no no
you're a member if you have
so if you own an nft you can go in yeah
but you could buy an nft for five
dollars okay no it has to be their nft
they minted that's a
like that hey oh okay
oh see to access the club members must
have a fly fish nft which is a unique
digital asset stored on the blockchain
and purchased using cryptocurrency the
company released
1501 tokens this month bringing in
around 15 million
so they're now saying
that you buy a token to even enter the
restaurant and they made 15 million
dollars before selling a piece of food
yep oh my god nobody knows the menu yet
oh it's not even open yet they're just
launching it this is the first thing you
can't get in even if i have even if i
have the booster i still can't get it
definitely not as a friday afternoon you
could buy a regular membership token on
the secondary market for the equivalent
of around 13 600
a token giving the holder access to an
even more exclusive tier which includes
access to private rooms serving omakasi
chef created multi-core sushi meals
could be had for the equivalent of 29.5
and that's just to get you in the door
you still have to pay for your meals
what if you don't like sushi though i
mean if a 29 000 ticket do you probably
have to go to a different nft restaurant
yeah so you imagine paying that 29.5 to
get in there and then be like this role
is outrageously priced oh yeah i can't
believe yeah that's my question is do
you have to then pay
do you have to then pay for my question
for food what happens in the soho house
do you pay for the food you have to pay
for everything yeah yeah so so so look
it's kind of insane so i've been to the
food's good though i've been to all the
soho houses here and i've been to seoul
houses all around the freaking world
world yeah yeah you know it's like if i
go on the road especially like in the uk
right yeah we got out we got off stage
and we're like all right let's go
somewhere we have company we have guests
where can we bring it to london we would
go to this we brought them to the soul
house that's the original yeah the
original well there's a few and then you
know they just we got a little room it's
always really cool like it's decorative
you saw there's like fireplaces couches
it's nice
cozy and yeah it's there's no dress code
there's no reservations
you have to make a reservation for the
restaurants you can just go i don't
believe they even take reservations you
just have to show up there's always room
no sometimes you gotta wait yeah
yeah sometimes you wait a little bit
yeah just a little bit but it's like i
go because it's like
one i want to see the space because
they're all pretty nice the food's
usually pretty good yeah and um it's
just a no-brainer for me right like oh
we got to go somewhere all right let
they have this they have a soho house
here all right let's go or another club
they have all the social goals all right
let's just go here and we don't have to
think about it and and hopefully no one
will will take pictures and stuff like
that oh you remember at any other social
clubs i just saw her house just so else
but there's this only one i've heard of
what's the other one no tim tim knows
them all yes tim dillon knows
five or six of them it's like a country
club but for artists he i saw him
railing on them once
well he rails on everything you didn't
want he want to be a part of it i think
i mean that is so tim but i don't know
what he's tim dillon showed up at my
house uh two weeks ago and and uh was
literally rang the bell and my daughter
answered the door because she was home
from school she goes tim's here and i
was like what and then i go and he was
like what's up buddy and then we went to
the uh diner and we had like a great
meal and he was making my kid laugh
hysterical and then he went to newark
airport and went home and then he went
into the night you know so
yeah i actually haven't spoken to him
since
i swear to god yeah and he called me
that day and got me riled up you saw
those messages i left you oh yes yeah
you riled them yeah yeah i was leaving
voice texts riled up yeah
yeah yeah all right we'll get into it
nick cannon confirms he's expecting
eighth child it's like nick is amish
with bree teasy now i just saw
nick cannon uh two three weeks ago i did
his show in the canon show nick's a nice
guy a nice nice guy he was wearing maybe
a ten thousand dollar suit and i had on
pants from like macy's
where does he get all his money from
his production company right got to be
wilding out yeah um all the movies he's
done i mean he's been the host of
america
yeah i get the host of a show what's his
net worth 30 shmills all right that's
pretty small
that's pretty i thought he was worth
more than that
but it's cool he's got a wild podcast
he's been on tv since he's like 14. yeah
he's got the old tv money but i thought
he had hundreds of millions that's why i
was like how does he have that much
money
what did what really is the number where
you don't like you just can live
like
like never have a problem again is it 50
million dollars well well really it's
just it's a sliding scale depending on
what you want right i mean if you if you
if you made 20 million dollars you
probably have you probably got
acclimated to a certain lifestyle then
your your answer to that question might
be like [ __ ] i wish i had like double a
triple this but before i even got on uh
on in the public with anything in
entertainment and i was my regular life
i would have sliced somebody's neck for
a million a million dollars like i mean
i don't know it used to mean something
to make him to be a millionaire to make
a million dollars i mean it still does
but yeah like it's people are selling
their farts and nfts and yeah and
and they're making millions of dollars
on youtube you know like it's just like
it doesn't it's not the same as when we
were younger what it meant we had a
million dollars is it it doesn't have
the same meaning now now it's like a
billion dollars or something right right
yeah yeah now it's like oh if you have
if you're a billionaire then you know
the most outrageous celebrity spending
habits of all time i also think it's
like the coasts you know but i think
somewhere in the middle of the country
like
everything else like way of life cost of
living property value is nowhere near
that absolutely their answer would
probably be way different than us what
would you what's the number what number
would make you
literally
never work again even even for the love
of it you're like [ __ ] the love i'm
gonna spend this money and and live my
life
i would say 25 million dollars 25
million 25 million in your bank account
i got not gross net you could go liquid
with 25 mil go liquid 25 mil because
what i'll tell you what i do stop comedy
i'd stop comedy i'd stop comedy with 25
million cash
i'd stop it i might still do like city
spots
yeah like no road no more right you
can't do one weekend a month right okay
just something okay have fun a little
bit okay 25 mil what's your plan my plan
is is to
i buy um what i what i would do is i
would take a million dollars of it and
i'd invest i i'd go i'd lean into crypto
i buy some bitcoin i asked my financial
advisor a couple of weeks ago if i
should dabble in crypto and he's like we
don't really do it and he goes and i
don't really recommend it it's still the
wild one he's got a fiduciary
responsibility to tell you that because
he can't really invest tell you invest
something that's so volatile it also all
crashed this week yeah it does it did
but it's been crashing i mean all you
hear are the other success stories you
hear like oh i made millions of dollars
you don't hear like people i lost
everything i had but but but but you
know you should put a percentage of it
into your you know like whatever
for falls so it's like if you if you're
okay with the money going down because
the plan is to not take it out for 10
years then who cares if it's if it's
volatile now right it should still i
mean still if you put money in bitcoin
five years ago you're still up
not even close you're up
like a hundred percent more than you'd
be in a bank a friend of mine was
talking to me about bitcoin
i'm gonna i'm gonna call it
seven eight seven years when did bitcoin
come out i think like 15 years ago or
something like that like seven eight
years ago my friend was talking about
trying to explain bitcoin to me a buddy
of mine on and uh he was telling
everyone who would listen
and and everyone was like yeah you know
we didn't buy and i think he bought a
lot of it and i i don't know what he
might be worth now i haven't seen him in
a bit but he's got to be he might have a
bengals he's been buying bitcoin for
like seven eight years just continuously
buying it yeah yeah though the thing is
the thing is if you did it it's like
anything else now that it's
so open in public you know how does he
get his money though cool how do you
sell your bitcoin and get money you have
to do it off the blockchain through an
app or through like a crypto wallet but
but who do you sell to for what price do
you make the price up did you sell it
back to that's what the stock the stock
is that day yeah yeah so if you sold it
today
for i don't know whatever it is thirty
six thousand dollars tomorrow it's fifty
six thousand dollars you know you you
you you dump it up right but what if you
done [ __ ] up what was the other way if
you bought it today for 36 and tomorrow
it's 56 you sell tomorrow you made
thousand dollars in one day you go home
if somebody else buys it though yes sir
but people might not buy it but people
not not buy it
and you gotta pay
dividends you only have to pay taxes
when you sell it right on the profit on
the profit yep and regular taxes i think
i think regular attacks yeah but the
thing is is it's
your account is right in the sense of it
is wild wild west like there's people i
read an article they got hacked what do
you love about babel i love babble if
it's it's not only the number one
language learning app it's my number one
language learning app okay i have been
brushing up on my espanol and i've also
been learning a little polyvu francais
whoa it's on the app they're fun ways to
learn scientifically proven to make a
difference it's not like when we used to
go to high school just memorize [ __ ] no
okay let me see 15 minute lessons i do
it on my go i could do it on the train
you know you could do it any way you
want true or false it's made by
artificial intelligence false most other
apps are these have actual linguistic
experts there's 14 languages all the
hits are there
okay yep uh you cannot and there's so
many ways to learn with babel in
additional lessons you can access
podcasts games videos stories even live
classes babble don't give [ __ ] no
babble is like the honey badger they're
the honey badgers
and right now if you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel b-a-b-b-e-l.com
use promo code hey babe that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code hey babe babble language for life
door dash baby
[Music]
what do you want to eat tonight maybe
you want a home-cooked favorite maybe
you don't
but
but it doesn't matter because if you
want something exciting new it would be
great to stay in tonight doordash
connects you with everything you want
whenever and however you want that's
right baby it's time to get back out
there but if you're not quite ready for
a full-blown adventure there's still
ways to explore the world from the
comfort of your home with doordash you
need to travel far to experience a new
dish it doesn't matter how long
restaurants you love you can now get
groceries and other essential items
delivered with doordash get drink snacks
and other household items in under an
hour that's a huge huge with over 300
000 partners you can support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
popeye's chipotle and cheesecake factory
and for a limited time our listeners are
going to get 25 off and zero delivery
fees on their first order 15 or more
when you download the doordarshan app
and enter code hey
that's 25 off up to a 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the door dash app in the
app store and enter code hey babe don't
forget that's code hey babe for 25 off
your first order with doordash subject
to change terms of life
it could get hacked too they said yeah
somebody hacked a big one and then and
then just gave everything back but he
just they said he wanted to show that
that there's a nice guy a breach how
easy it is to have a hole in the
security yeah it was a big article i
read last week well i know if you're in
coinbase sure you're insured up to like
250 000 you're insured from who i think
from coinbase which is the app like well
okay so if you get hacked and lose that
up to 250 grand they're liable for
what about over over then i think you're
they're more back in the wild west
right but what i'm saying is if i am a
small-time investor and
i get
you know
hacked with my hundred thousand dollar
you know maybe i built it up two hundred
thousand dollars okay fine they get me
they give me it back but what if i'm
someone that's trading like 40 million
dollars with it and then i get hacked
they're gonna give me well because what
because you can only get it hacked if
the money and bitcoins are online in
coinbase or on some type of server but
what you could do is you can take the
coins off line and put them on like a
memory stick and memorize a code of
numbers that they can't hack it because
you have it that's what we were
listening we were hearing about during
the boom a year or two ago when people
were they threw out a hard drive that
had the thing and it was in the garbage
jumper it was worth 50 million dollars
right right right and then yeah people
you bought one coin i got one coin one
bitcoin i got one b
one btz and you didn't do east nothing
else no uh i got some ether i got some
ether and i got a couple of alt coins
but i'm not heavy in the game like that
you know what i mean
but what do i have to do to get eth i'd
go on coinbase and get some eth i would
go one i would go one bitty witty and
and couple of easts because east is the
platform that the bitty whitty is made
on but again i really don't understand
what i'm doing right and my children
might be suffering because of my
cryptocurrency eth is the platform that
bit is made on yes eth i think is the
blockchain i thought ethan was another
bitcoin no nfts are made on on east yeah
i think that's what you're thinking of
no but ethereum is this is also the part
of the it's gold and silver
no but i think ethereum is where the
bitcoin is made i'm pretty sure ethereum
is the blockchain this is like the new
birds in the beast
i look real good today i look real good
today
um
all right so when you bought your bit
how much i bought my bitty witty it was
like 30 grand and now and it went all
the way up to 69. okay and now it's back
down to 34. and you just you just hold
tight i just hold it because you're not
going to sell at 69 because you're like
where could this go i got remember you
and i talked about this last year i got
nervous i sold it immediately lost money
i said i hate this feeling of selling it
and this and that i said just i i
literally now i've deleted the coinbase
app off my phone
and i have it on a um
little atomic wallet like i have it like
i've i've taken the bitcoin offline so
now i just have it and i have a bunch of
uh words in my head that that is the
password and if you forget them it's
rendered useless yeah you're done so you
you have a little thing worth thirty six
thousand dollars and if you don't
remember the code to it it's worth
nothing worth nothing so how do you
remember how do you well i have it
memorized and then i have it written
down
uh somewhere and then i also um uh
that's it i have it written down
your memory's good
well wait so what if you want to
purchase something using bitcoin
then i could i could convert the bitcoin
into cash but then i'll have to pay
taxes on it
so
people that say we take bitcoin yeah how
do they accept bitcoin that i because i
think whatever the price of something is
they take the percentage of the bitcoin
so if something's i don't know a
thousand bucks and it's
0.02 percent of your bitcoin and and so
so you can you can type in your bitcoin
number and purchase with bitcoin and you
said yeah how do you do that i don't
know i don't know how they actually get
the bitcoin
that i don't know because i've never
tried to do that all right but you could
also buy ethereum with bitcoin you can
buy crypto with other crypto
you can yeah
okay so let me ask you a question right
now should we buy you gonna see this
girl an ape former miss usa chesley
crist who jumped to her death i went on
a date with her and she passed away she
committed suicide two days ago very hard
but i went on a date with her like in
2018 get out of here 19. such a nice
sweet woman miss former miss usa i i
actually uh almost dated him miss usa
remember i told you i told you this
story yeah i met her at espn uh the espn
zone in in in uh times square you never
told us this no you know i did i would
have missed usa at the espn zone no i
did i did i did go on with me no i told
you the
the fact that you want to because miss
usa in the espn zone is like a cartoon i
want to write no no i went there to
watch the games and then she was at the
bar drinking alone i was with like three
or four friends and uh i ended up
talking to her and she was real cool she
knew she like she knew the game and
everything like she like really liked
liked football and was like into it and
when she came and ended up sitting down
with us for the whole time and then we
laughed we cried it was better than cats
and at the end of it she said i gotta
tell you something uh i i won miss i was
miss usa just so you know whatever
because she gave me a number and
everything and i was like oh all right
cool yeah and then um we exchange a few
phone calls back and forth and uh never
end up dating her name was kate schindle
kate schindle yeah let's
there it is
kate schindle
there you go and she was miss america in
1998 yeah kate schindle
there you go
yeah and at the espn zone yeah
just drinking a beer by herself watching
the game 100
like a hundred beers
[Laughter]
no no she was just sitting there just
drinking a beer this bien zone isn't
even there anymore it's not i know the
one time i went to the espn zone my aunt
took me there and i was so looking
forward to it for my birthday i had a
cold couldn't taste the food ah
covered yeah i called it i called it
1996.
you know you know it's getting insane
now
both my daughters everybody in my now
because at first i was saying in my
family i'm not getting covered my
offspring never got covered my
daughter's never got it but now even
they got covered and i still haven't
gotten it
both the baby got it
how do you know
because
the older one had it and then my baby
fever
you know uh
and you still didn't get it still
nothing you've never had it tested a
hundred times
zero wild it
my boy said two weeks two more weeks i
don't get it going they're starting to
study they're going to start a study you
ready for this what study i'm going to
be a part of they're going to do it
they're going to give me cove at 19 and
see what happens it's a big study go
google study giving people covet 19 this
is a big thing that i you only qualify
for it if you never got any of it wow
new study gives insight uh no it's um
no it's like um giving people covenant
yeah it's it's uh it's a giving people
cover 19 research study or some [ __ ]
like that it just came out a couple will
you do it
i mean
no i this isn't it because this is
august 31st this just came out a couple
of days all right maybe it's not that
big maybe it's just like
in uh
yeah yeah would you do it for what
you're going to do to help the greater
good
i guess i'll do it to help degra i mean
i might ask if they can give me a board
ape or something like that right but but
but i yeah i mean
it's just a little insane why how i
never got it and less and less and less
and less and less i just never tested my
antibodies right
because but they're saying but
again my doctor friend is like i don't
you did i tested i in fairness i haven't
tested my antibodies in four months okay
but i was in contact with it
five times before that and tested the
antibodies that never even had the
antibodies i don't know i don't
understand it
so should we buy a board ape right now
would you like to buy one pimp should we
go three-way on it
what what do we what are we doing here
should we buy a board ape and just let
it ride
should we yeah
should we give pimp aboard ape and
consider that his raise
[Laughter]
bieber buys it okay that's 500 eth
how do i buy
open an online account with any crypto
exchange got one download a crypto
wallet such as metamask to link
i mean listen to what we're saying it
sounds like like like greek dude in 2019
we would never be talking about
wallets and this and variants and all
it's like we're living in a different
world just two years later by the way
i'm not drinking uh i'm not gonna have
uh sip of alcohol until august 26 my
birthday zero alcohol is that right zero
wow going zero for eight months zero
alchiwaki until august 26th unbelievable
we're gonna have a big one i'm gonna get
[ __ ] smash nice why is that because
of what you did this weekend to yourself
yes this year i just i had to wake up
and say it's a louboutin cleanse it's a
louboutin cleanse and i've been i
literally because i've always been like
i don't drink i don't drink i don't
drink lit literally like i did the math
in my head
the last 48 days in a row i've had at
least one sip of alcohol 48 days in a
row i've had alcohol at some point in
the day sometimes i've been smashed
sometimes it's just been a sip yeah it's
been i don't know what the hell's been
going on i just wow wine martinis you
know sometimes i've been getting
hammered yeah
doing shows
i made uh two or three martinis in the
house the other night for the first time
really yeah just i was just i i had a
night off it was the weekend it was a
snowstorm and i sat down to watch a
movie and i made some martinis did you
like them you're all in martini my own
yeah they were good yeah they were good
all right so i'm in open c
i think i have an open c account i think
how'd you get an open c account because
i wanted to get into this and so like
months ago i i think i had had someone
make me one
okay so these are all owned or these are
all for sale both
so how much is one let's see so you
could look at all 10 000 of them right
here they're all documented
so you could go look at like at bieber's
right on here yeah it should be on here
if he still has it up so can you click
on one pimpy and see how much we can one
could go for how is it how is it that
they could make 10 000 different apes so
this is only 148
no that's ethereum so it's 398 000 yes
that yes
yep
398. what how do they make
how do they make it enough
how do they make enough variation in
them that they could make 10 000.
and they're all original i mean i know
well because they're different paint
like will they will they do that exact
thing different colors
you know look look you can see the rest
of them go go back to the rest of them
pimping if you can it's going back yeah
see they're all different ones yeah but
i'm saying there's 10 000 of them yeah
so like are you telling me that they're
really ten thousand unique
or like that guy right there with the
pink hair they'll sell another one him
with blue hair another one's a yellow
hair
[Laughter]
so do they can you arrange them in a
pricey order has got a different one is
a pink hair with a blue background the
other one was a booger green what does
that say at the top what does that say
is this stat up top
low to high but scroll up go hide a lot
what does that say 10 000 items
6.2 000 owners
floor price
118.69
volume traded okay
okay
go to um high to low let's see what the
top one is
yeah let's go what's this one what
what's this guy and i don't know why
he's so
why is this guy valued so much so this
one is 100 trillion dollars
yes is that am i seeing that right
100 billion
so how much is 100 billion each each so
what is that 26
920 that how many how what is that price
it's four
one two one three three four is that 267
billion no it's more than that one two
that's million billion trillion it's
what's above trillion
that can't be right
that can't be right make an offer
five
no that doesn't make any sense
wait go back to that one more time
that's insane we'll go back to that one
more time
take that number and put it in
that number and put it into google and
see whether so we're on open c we're on
the board eight yacht club we're looking
at the number one priced uh uh
board ape
did it imagine
so it's it's an imaginable it's un
unimaginable because a million is there
that means that's billion that's
trillion what's above trillion quad
quadrillion trillion even bezos can't
buy that puppy what's above trillion
gazillion zillion gazillion or trillion
now after a trillion there comes a
knowner quadrillion quadrillion
so it's 267 quadra that's more money
than we have in the world yeah it's not
it's it's it's not even so that's just a
so who sets that price i guess the
market people that no the people that
made these things that meant that might
be somebody trolling you know so go go
back to a more realistic one because
they might be trying to aim for people
like us looking high to low
to see so go down i mean they're
overshooting they're they're
overshooting even jeff bezos at 267
quadrille let's see this one what's this
one 3001 go ahead click on this guy but
what makes so what what gives 16.7
million dollars this one oh
my god
looks good
but who is going to buy it
some of the guys from succession 7
million roy would logan roy buy this i
like this one he might actually he might
i'm trying to get logan roy to give me a
shout out video on cameo no response
logan roy yeah the actor that plays logo
brian cox yeah i'm trying to get brian
he's on cameo no he's not on cameo we're
trying to get a shot i'm trying to go
like to his age and get it just get a
shout out
well why i don't know i just put on my
instagram
[Laughter]
so wait
yeah so but what what
what if i buy and then if i buy one okay
do i put the price tag on it when i want
to sell it i or is it like how does it
how does it go
that's a good question and pimp another
question is is there just one person
making these one artist
that well that collection was a single
artist or somebody who paid a artist to
make it for them by the way has got
corduroy shirt and pants on if you came
you have to come one day with corduroy
socks and a corduroy hat and you'll look
like um the the the rock from the
fantastic four was that guy's name oh
the thing the thing you look like yeah
dude i've i wish your name was roy
because quarter roy would be a great i
know i like i i know cool i i i say pimp
is in quarter and i spell it quarter
q-u-a-r-t-e-r corduroy and people scream
at me they're like you idiot that's how
you spell it i'm like oh look at dumb
old me i don't
you look i swear you really look
like
you
there's a piano in your home yeah
you you host dinner parties
you've you have invested in a horse i
look like i'm in succession i look like
i'm in because i've been watching the
show so much i look like i'm roman roy
you do you look like you have a sailboat
now is this my look i know
i like it i don't see you in these
colors in this style too often you want
to see another surprise from the side
it looks like you married someone from
this kind of family and she changed you
she changed me but she can't change me
all the way because look at me from the
side i'm get cutting my hair into a
mullet
yeah i saw that fade bro what do you
think of it i saw that are you really
going yeah you know what seven you ever
heard of the haircut is seven it was
like a big haircut with colombia but i
guess i could tell what it is i'm going
with seven yeah you're doing that i'm
doing going to mullet like
not going to be the only one with the
mic
you're going to do you're going to have
theo's hair theo's got a southern mullet
i'm going with a northern mullet so is
that the first step this is the first
step i'm going with the union mullet
did you do that purposely or did they
just do it and that's what you got i
said for the one time in my life i want
to grow a mullet and see how i feel and
so far i don't feel great
why didn't you do it all why didn't you
just do it all well this is what he said
this
he said he cuts here and then he slowly
grows it out into the mullet what do you
think no good i gotta see it i would
love to see you in a mullet i could
probably go to get to mullet right now
right if i just say right now you
actually it literally is just it's just
a trim
that should be a punishment that's great
oh jesus
uh it's extra how to sell an nfc it's
extremely hard as with any other
business that requires work and
intelligence
merely listing nfts without having a
prior audience or online presence and
expecting that to sell them is
short-sighted i understand that too
because i wanted to also see about like
i wanted to get into it and buy it and
become part of the community actually so
that like in the future if i want to
trade them or whatever with them i'm i'm
literally you know in in the community
i'm i'm someone that's lending to the
community of nfts yeah and you you
notice now when when people there was a
lot of blowback about because it it's
bad for the environment to and the
blockchain isn't to mention to mine
crypto right or and to do the nfts like
the power it takes yeah but you see that
you don't hear a lot of those criticisms
anymore no because it's too much money
it is right yeah it's too much money by
the way
i s um my um uh um
you know it was big snowstorm
snow ice all that
i
left the salt
left my salt inside my house stupid move
i think i was i think of my family and
i've been breathing in
salt mist
and yeah because i've had a burning
sensation in my throat i love mine in
the house i had it in a bag though i
closed the bag no see i had a big open
hole in the bag and i think and i'm
almost positive my daughter ate a couple
of those oh man what what can you do
yeah you can't do anything about that no
that you can't do anything about it no i
just but to be honest with you for the
first time ever in my life ever i'm
not considering leaving new york but the
thought has popped to my head where i'm
like i kind of don't want to deal with
the cold anymore i really was like
uncomfortable and i'm crissy cold
weathers right i was just uncomfortable
this last couple days in the cold and i
was like what am i doing where you going
what are you thinking
florida
too hot in the summer
that's a lot in florida's a lot too much
where would you go if it wasn't new york
considering climate or no
yeah
oh oh man i don't know we talked about
this we said san fran was the place we
liked it the weather but the prices are
outrageous and you'll get shot and
killed in the streets yeah
yeah i don't know new york is it for me
really no it's new maybe
yeah you know it'll be the best actually
london
oh yeah international because the
weather is great you know 55 to 70
raining all the time i love it yeah
barely snow do you love snow in london i
don't know
does it does it ever snow in london i
don't think so it has to below freezing
not uncommon snow is not unheard
of yeah so it's it's
it's not saying like so never really
snow it's not like a snow storm oh look
at heathrow on average some snow sleet
occurs in average 12 days during the
winter season from november april that's
we don't get more than 12 snow days here
do we i mean i but i feel like it's not
you would never say that snow is not
unheard of in new york snow is likely in
new york yeah if for them to say it's
not unheard of right it's not that big
i'm going to london this summer going to
do shows
and i want to go to italy
so
uh
february 5th
this saturday oh it's this saturday yeah
so this is coming out two days before it
yeah saturday okay so speaking theater
in two in two days new york city at the
beacon theater speaker theater sold out
um you're going to come back i'm going
to come home sal is going to come solid
babe's going to come and uh may
14th
rhymes sneak in theater as well
sal
at the beacon theater
rhymes with it rhymes with it rhymes
with beacon theater aka the streak in
theater because i'm going to come run
across that stage naked before you go on
that's it
so nothing's up yet nothing's on the
internet yet nothing's on sale yet but
just so you know new yorkers i've never
headlined here before in my life and
i've been waiting to do it for years and
finally
your boys coming home boys coming so to
the beaker theater may 14th will board
apes tickets
can they get in we will take board 18.
yes also ticketmaster but board ape as
well 100 i think honestly we really
should look at a board at board ape and
invest
you want to do it as long as there's one
that's like
not um like
under a million no like i mean like
there's some that are like can we get
can we still get one for like 25k no
200k 200k is is the basement i think so
a [ __ ] board app is 200k yeah but
let me show you guys there's 10 000
board apes if i and the first one was
worth 267 quadrillion dollars if i'm
buying the 200 000 board ape right
although is everybody else or the other
nine thousand people looking at me like
he's got a [ __ ] ape yeah he's got the
bottom basement ape
but my question is is within fleisch
might go down a little bit but that 200k
board ape could be worth 600k by the end
of the year
we could make look forward
but who's going to buy it
only somebody else looking for an ape
how about this
we're going to invest in this board ape
we'd want to take one more co-investor
we're only opening it up to one to a
third co-investor but you have to have
proof of your ticket march 11th at the
ryman theater in nashville tennessee
when sal and i are co-headlining at the
ryman theater in nashville tennessee if
you have proof of purchase of that
ticket you
enter the lottery to be the third
co-investor of the 200 000 [ __ ]
board eighth that we're gonna buy that's
exactly right
and
this has been hey babe this has been hey
babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey